Tom sprints! Tom leaps! Tom
hangs on for dear life. It's
time to set your brain for Cruise control.
Right out of the gate, we have to
talk about Tom's tendency to run,
because this particular trademark has
reached levels of absurdity at this point.
"Don't run."
"You don't have to chase me."
"You don't have to run."
Dating all the way back to 1981's "TAPS," Tom
has found a way to show off his incredible knack
for sprinting in all but a handful of films.
The legal drama "The Firm" gave him several
opportunities to dash around in a suit, and
Cameron Crowe even figured out a way to slip
a sequence of Tom's running technique into
two non-action films: the opening of 2001's
mind-bending drama "Vanilla Sky" and the tail end
of the 1996 romantic comedy/drama "Jerry Maguire."
Those were mere warmups. Nowadays, when Tom
runs — he runs. You need only pop in any of
the "Mission: Impossible" features to catch
a glimpse of his fancy footwork. In fact,
J.J. Abrams devotes nearly an entire
minute of the climax of "Mission:
Impossible 3" to Tom literally sprinting
in pursuit of the film's key villain.
The latest trailer for "Mission: Impossible
— Dead Reckoning Part One" teases viewers
with a brief shot of the man, the myth, the
legend running through a mysterious locale
immediately following his name credit. So, yeah,
at this point, it seems Tom is in on the joke.
Tom's wild stunts weren't always a staple in his
films. There are no death-defying leaps off of
high rises in "Rain Man" or vertigo-inducing jet
battles in "Eyes Wide Shut," but the actor still
managed to show off his need for adrenaline-fueled
antics early in his career. Case in point:
In "The Outsiders," Tom's character does a
backflip for no apparent reason after running
out of a house. According to actor Rob Lowe
in an interview with Entertainment Tonight,
director Francis Ford Coppola asked the
cast to learn how to do a backflip and
Tom was the only one capable of
pulling off the difficult feat.
"Check this out, buddy."
The actor also insisted on driving a real
NASCAR racecar in "Days of Thunder," and
according to a profile in Rolling Stone, rode
the fastest horse on set during the climactic
land race in "Far and Away." It's small potatoes
compared to the stunts he achieves in "The Mummy"
and the "Mission: Impossible" films and his
other action-based roles, but worth noting.
So, why does he do it? During an
appearance on "The Graham Norton
Show," Tom admitted it all comes
down to the storytelling, saying:
"I feel that you're bringing everything, you know,
physically and emotionally, to a character
in a story. I've trained for 30 years doing
[stunts] and it allows us to put cameras in
places where you are normally not able to."
Not only is Tom Cruise a thrill junkie, but
he also loves himself a slick motorcycle — a
fact made abundantly clear when the actor
memorably rode a Kawasaki GPZ900R along an
airport runway in 1986's "Top Gun."
Over 35 years later, Tom once again
hopped aboard a Kawasaki — the Ninja H2 to
be exact, a.k.a. the fastest motorcycle in
the world — for the enormously successful
sequel "Top Gun: Maverick." In the interim,
Tom has thrilled audiences with his astonishing
motorcycle skills in John Woo's "Mission:
Impossible II," Joseph Kosinski's "Oblivion,"
and "Mission: Impossible — Fallout."
Tom's love for motorcycles extends off-screen
as well. Apparently, after wrapping a project,
the actor will take home or purchase
the motorcycle used in the film and
add it to his vast collection. According
to Motorious, Tom has in his possession
the BMW S1000 RR used in "Mission: Impossible
— Rogue Nation," the Triumph Thruxton used in
"Edge of Tomorrow," and yes, even that
Kawasaki from "Top Gun," among others.
And if motorcycles don't exist in the context
of the movie, Tom will usually hop on a horse
instead, but we say that counts. What is
a horse if not a motorcycle with legs?
While many of Tom's movies feature the box
office star working alongside a group of notable
co-stars, there always seems to be a moment where
his character must cut the rip cord and go solo to
save the day. We see this often in the "Mission:
Impossible" franchise in which Tom's IMF Agent
Ethan Hunt leaves his teammates in the dust to
go one-on-one with the film's principal bad guy.
"We didn't have this conversation. You don't
know where I am, if I'm dead or alive."
But this trait also extends to some of the
actor's more dramatic ventures. Notably,
in "A Few Good Men," Tom's cocky lawyer
ignores the advice of his team and takes
on Jack Nicholson's sharp-tongued
Colonel Nathan Jessep all on his own.
Likewise, in 2008's "Valkyrie," based
on real events, Tom's one-armed,
one-eyed Colonel plots with an assortment
of German officers to assassinate Adolf
Hitler and ends up planting the bomb
himself. Other Cruise vehicles such
as "Minority Report," "Jack Reacher,"
"Born on the Fourth of July," and "The
Firm" position Tom against an evil or corrupt
establishment that he must battle on his own.
"I am not a hero. I'm a
drifter with nothing to lose."
You can't really discuss Tom Cruise without
acknowledging his vast collection of shades.
Whether he's mixing drinks on the beach,
driving Dustin Hoffman cross country,
or simply jumping out of explosions, Tom
Cruise has an eye for a classy pair of eyewear.
In "Risky Business" and "Top Gun," Tom
slid on Ray-Bans and helped popularize
the brand in the 1980s, according to Mental Floss.
"There's one thing I've learned in all my
years. Sometimes you gotta say, 'What the f—.'"
And in "Top Gun: Maverick," the
shades were so important that
his Ray-Bans were custom-made to fit his face.
In other words: It ain't a Tom Cruise film
unless it features Tom Cruise in sunglasses.
"Thank you."
Aside from a few exceptions, Tom is typically the
de facto star of the films he appears in. So yeah,
it makes sense that his character always ends up
saving the day from the forces of evil. Of course,
that's outside of films where he is the force
of evil, like "Interview with the Vampire" and
"Collateral." And even in "Collateral," his
cold-hearted assassin influences Jamie Foxx's
world-weary cab driver enough to force a
positive change in the young man's life,
which can technically be seen as
a win for Tom. Without Vincent,
it's doubtful Max ever finds the confidence needed
to dump his crappy job and move on with his life.
Otherwise, Tom is typically the man of
the hour by the final reel of any film.
Whether its stopping dastardly terrorists or
corrupt operatives from destroying the world,
saving Iceman and Rooster in the "Top Gun"
films, or taking down an alien tripod to save his
daughter in "War of the Worlds," you can pretty
much count on Tom Cruise to get the job done.
"Yeah baby."
No matter the circumstances, Tom Cruise characters
always get the girl. In "Risky Business," he ends
up with Lana, the sensitive sex worker. "Top
Gun" sees our beleaguered hero ride off with
Kelly McGillis, and "Minority Report" rewards his
efforts by fixing him up with his estranged wife.
In "A Few Good Men," it's strongly
hinted that Demi Moore has eyes for Tom,
while Cameron Diaz locks lips with
our main man in "Knight and Day."
Those are just a few examples, but it's clear:
Tom's characters can get any woman they want. Now,
whether they're attracted to the killer
good looks, impeccable fashion sense,
or heart swelling one-liners
is a topic worth discussing.
Tom Cruise may be the king of cool, but
even the most even-keeled action heroes
lose their patience every now and again. And
God forbid you get in his way when it happens.
As it turns out, an explosive temper is
practically a trademark of his characters.
It's little wonder that Ben Stiller cast
him as the foul-mouthed Les Grossman in
the 2008 comedy "Tropic Thunder."
Hidden under layers of prosthetics,
Tom shouts, curses, and dances away with the film,
revealing a darker side that somehow fits
snugly amidst the comic antics of the movie.
More dramatically, in "A Few Good Men," Tom
rages against Demi Moore after she makes an
error and even does the "toss everything off
the desk" bit for good measure. In "Mission:
Impossible," he justifiably loses his cool
after his entire team is killed during a
mission gone wrong. He even gets a little
grumpy at his kids in "War of the Worlds."
"I'm not hungry either."
"You're not hungry either?
Fine."
These are but a few examples of
Tom's ability to blow a gasket,
but make no mistake, Tom has many captivating
tantrums throughout his filmography.
Save for his overweight character Les Grossman,
Tom typically carries an incredible physique
that he's clearly not afraid to show
off at every possible opportunity.
In "Jack Reacher," for example, Tom sheds
his shirt and attempts to carry a serious
conversation with Rosamund Pike's Helen Rodin.
Likewise, in the action comedy "Knight and Day,"
Tom wows Cameron Diaz during a foray on a tropical
island. In "Mission: Impossible — Rogue Nation,"
he sheds his top for an exciting fight sequence
during which he crunches up a pole to escape. And
who could forget the infamous volleyball scene
in "Top Gun?" Hey, if you've got it, flaunt it.
"I'm sorry, could you please put a shirt on?"
"This is my shirt."
We've already discussed Tom's obsession
with motorcycles, but that's only part of
the story. Nearly every Tom Cruise movie
features the actor going really fast,
either by running, driving, flying,
boating, or vampiric trickery.
"Top Gun" is the obvious choice here, but
also consider Ron Howard's dramatic epic
"Far and Away," in which Tom hops on a horse
and outruns everyone to claim his piece of
Oklahoma property. Or, how about "Minority
Report," where he leaps around on cars on a
futuristic highway? He rides a speeding
car off a bridge in "Vanilla Sky," and,
of course, much of "Days of Thunder"
takes place on a race track.
So, yeah, Tom Cruise means it when he says…
"I feel the need, the need for speed."
"Ow!"
And while almost all his movies feature Tom's
characters going fast, it's not uncommon for the
actor himself to be hitting the same speeds.
In fact, Newsweek notes that in "Top Gun:
Maverick," the actor took to the skies
in an actual fighter jet, while "Mission:
Impossible — Fallout" gave him a chance to fly
a helicopter through snow-covered mountains.
Smithsonian Magazine details how "American Made"
allowed the actor to put his pilot's license to
use and perform intense flying sequences in a
six-seater Piper Aerostar 600 and a Cessna 414.
It's a weird trademark, but at some point in many
of Tom's films, the actor is forced to hang onto
something for dear life. "Mission: Impossible —
Rogue Nation," might take the cake for literal
representation of it, but there are actually
so many instances of the superstar clinging
to the side of something or other in a desperate
attempt to keep himself from falling. In "Knight
and Day," the action maestro hangs onto Cameron
Diaz's car while battling bad guys; in "War of
the Worlds" he hangs onto a group of strangers
to avoid being sucked into an alien ship; and he
spends most of "Rock of Ages" barely clinging
to his own sanity. Which…that counts, right?
Perhaps most famously, Tom hung off of the side
of the massive Burj Khalifa building for "Mission
Impossible: Ghost Protocol." Even "Edge of
Tomorrow" featured the actor clinging to an
object — a machine gun attached to a military
aircraft — during the action-packed climax.
At the end of the day, we'll continue to enjoy
his many death-defying feats for as
long as he's willing to perform them.